jump into
that one they have played two draws so
far these two and uh it was close uh for
to a win for a young christophe duda in
game two it ended with a draw that means
they are still tied and here and here
has the white pieces in game three
what does this look like
so it's early days but white has adopted
the reti setup that means developing the
knight pushing a pawn this kind of
really nice compact structure around the
white king
and black meanwhile is going for a
double fianchetto so he's pushed two
pawns on the flanks and he's going to
put his bishops on long diagonals
slightly going against the rules
conventional rules normally would say
nights before bishops but
duda trying to get away with things here
do you think his lighting his camera
does it match his mood right now just
darkness
after that last uh after that last game
yeah i think so yeah so he's gone
to the dark side
it must be hard after a
blunder like in that game losing uh
sort of his chance to win that game
with just 15 minutes to get ready for
the next one yeah i could i could see a
niche really putting the pressure on
this game i mean it's a good situation
he's got the white pieces um he's got
kind of you know already i'd say a more
niche position you know slow maneuvering
chances for an advantage
and duda has played as david said a very
unconventional setup i mean the main
problem with dude is you know
positionally is that his light square
bishop is just pointing its own pawn so
it's like you know you're trapping
yourself uh behind a wall basically
which you can't get out of and the other
bishop which a niche has is is very
strong in these positions so so i
certainly certainly think white has
chances to gain advantage out of the
opening here yeah quite significantly
ahead in development as well white's
already castled the king away to safety
so
anish is able to open up the position
very quickly i quite like this move um
black has two
possible replies i was going to say
either you can uh just kind of
defend this pawn maybe with a pawn
yourself or you can
capture just to open up your bishop but
this
bishop is undefended maybe there would
have been some consequences instead duda
brings his knight out and after a
capture he just castles his king and
uh this is interesting he will win this
pawn back on the next move there's no
way to
really defend it if you throw your pawn
forward in the center this guy just gets
captured so um in the position right now
yeah i was going to say something along
these lines for energy just move your
rook across get ready to build this nice
pawn center looks really good it looks
really weird
wonderful for white definitely i i i um
you know this dude on tilt i i think so
i mean we seen duda go on tilt before i
remember when magnus surprised him with
a very strange opening move
one f3 he
he just drew that game and then the next
game he just cracked and lost he was
very lucky to draw that game he was
losing yeah
yeah and i mean this this is a bit like
the grunfeld one of your favorite
openings uh david but a really bad
version of it uh because
you don't have the grunt filled pressure
and you're getting kicked around by
white's pieces so white's gonna have a
fantastic center anisha's not gonna get
a better chance in this to to take a
lead i think i mean beautiful for white
this is everything you want from an
opening right simon yeah definitely this
bishop you mentioned getting kicked
around it's moved three times now
already in the opening that's where he's
lost the
uh lost the tempo uh tempi
plural of tempo and uh yeah right now
these two pawns
yeah looking fantastic if you challenge
them they can just simply step forward
and black probably won't even be able to
challenge them in the future either as
well because
i mean that's not going to be easy to
orchestrate and i was always taught
by my well by my very first coach who
was from serbia and he was a great coach
and he gave very generous generalistic
rules and he said if you get this it was
a milos pavlovic i was working with him
for about two years
and uh i i got my first coach when i was
about 27. all right i thought you're
like you're gonna say seven no tony
seven yeah and um
he was like yeah if you get something
like this you're positionally one yeah
and he said you know because you're just
gonna have the capability to march
forward with your pawns and your pieces
and if black can't do anything about it
they're lost
yeah it's probably as simple as that
really it's very simplistic but totally
simplistic but it's free you know it's
very it gives you a lot of hope and uh
gives you a lot of motivation yeah and
at other levels other than this elite
level i mean yeah just don't give up
though it's black just develop your
pieces try and maybe just hold some
squares keep your pieces nice and
compact but unfortunately for duda
someone like giri will be able to find
the best squares for white pieces he
will be able to step forward at the
right moment
and yeah it's just one sided traffic at
the moment it's just all about these
pawns this is a slight slight weakness
in dude's game isn't it i mean i i think
i actually tipped him into candidates to
to do really well uh to actually be one
of the chances to qualify but in the
first game he kind of threw away uh a
nicely one position against uh alireza
and uh then after that his play was not
impressive and did he tilt i think so i
think he's i think he's again like we
talked about emotional players i think
he's a very emotional player when things
are going well he can just wipe everyone
off the board win win win but when
something goes a little bit wrong it
affects him more than you know like
let's say magnus carson is the best at
bouncing back uh but he is something he
could certainly try to work on a bit
and he i like it does look like it's
getting darker and darker
i know it's probably getting darker
outside but he look he does look like an
evil villain now doesn't it he really
does oh yeah with his hands like this as
well
in a dark hair a cat to jump
is yeah the villain out james bond okay
this is white carrots i'm actually
walking into a room and you just see
that yeah
yeah you mean come and enter david take
a seat
i will tell you your fortune
oh and he's not too happy young
christopher duda this is uh game three
between anish and duda now look at that
uh young samuel savion has won the
second game against huey he's taken the
lead now in that match report against uh
zhong that is game two still going on on
the bar is slightly over to the young
american side
we are asking you guys today which match
you want us to keep the closest eye on
and
i think we have the live poll right here
okay so it's still levon aronian again
sergeant arigaisi your favorite match to
follow duda against geary in second
place you can cast your vote either on
the champions chess tour page on
instagram or on twitter and also if you
retweet the poll on twitter you are in
contention to win one year subscription
to chess 24 premium so go ahead cast
your vote and help us decide which games
to follow
this is game three between anish and
duda they are tied before this game but
it's looking good now for a niche it's
looking very good for anish he chooses
this square for the bishop slightly
surprising to me because black can just
uh do something that you've alluded to
simon in the past just kick back this
bishop black can push a pawn on the side
of the board i don't think this bishop
wants to trade itself off for the black
knight
maybe anish wants to provoke a pawn push
around the black king just it might
weaken the black king's side later on
but uh yeah the problems remain for
black okay we see this pawn push happen
he does step back so maybe that black
pawn
will uh
well dude we'll have to lose some time
protecting it later but yeah problems
remain white's pawn center
hard to touch
and okay he does just try to prevent the
white pawns from stepping forward very
logical this last move at least from
duda
levon aronian and erica is your favorite
match to follow
game three
will start uh quite soon eric is still
in the lead and if he wins game three
then he will uh win that match he will
be ready for the semi finals and since
this is your favorite match to follow we
will of course
follow game three when this one finishes
maybe with a win for a niche
so uh i guess we all like white's
position right
what would be the next plan what
should we be looking for here
i mean
put the rook in the middle
i mean just just get the absolutely
ideal setup if you can um so yeah push
the queen connect the rooks and this is
kind of like
it's a great example to show beginners
maybe this this
this game because you you take the
center you get all your pieces and
they're on the best squares and then you
then you can think about what to do um
you don't need to rush doing something
but you make as many useful moves as you
can right first
beautiful you know it really is i mean
you can push a pawn at some point maybe
you could do something on the king's
side and
yeah he's he's going for this just put
the rook in the middle and it's
everything is ideal really then
and then and then it's quite a lazy way
to play as well so you don't really have
to calculate much you just do this we
first think later yeah yeah and it's
it's i mean at some point you have to do
something obviously but you know i mean
you can think about that later
maybe even go
move as many pawns you can
the h pawn the a pawn the b pawn just
take as much space
as possible
and uh he's going for your plan simon
very natural play and i love this
position for white so much
i'm completely crushing on it um yeah i
mean look at the white half of the board
literally the first four ranks we
control every single square um okay
maybe not these two but they're not so
relevant and yeah it's just complete
control black's just huddled
all right that's all in the box but okay
so we've been waxing lyrical as we say
in the uk about white's position what
about black i mean is there any chance
for him to do some repair work i don't
know
step the queen forward also connect
brooks and then
try for something i mean a try being the
operative word i mean if i was black i'd
be looking at yeah he's he's gone for it
trying to place the c pawn forwards but
it just always seems like it's a bad
move
and the black knight on the side of the
board
is horrible right i mean it's it's just
sort of hanging there um
and it's weird this this kind of
position you you could probably show to
a lot of you know a lot of players and
they'd be like well why is white doing
so well i can't see a plan for white and
it is kind of like you don't actually in
chess always have to do something you
know you can win games by just doing
nothing sometimes taking space improving
improving improving something will turn
up i mean
and he's doing that right here just
getting tactics always working your
favor right if if your piece is
centralized like this if you control the
center with pawns
after this rook move i mean what's the
stop and he's just pushing this pawn
forward and it looks like you're risk
trapping this night
um i guess you don't have to be so hasty
you can kind of wait you can
maybe get the white queen out of the
line of this black rook
maybe that would be the kind of
pragmatic approach just shuffle the
queen across somewhere
eyeing up this knight which yeah you
mentioned simon it's just
the worst piece on the board by a mile
right now okay he does push this pawn
um so he wants to
definitely kick back this knight
oh the evaluation bar goes down though
so maybe this means that black can break
out now with a pawn push
okay
it looked to me like this is just uh
terrible for black anyway for example
oh i think i realized why i was going to
say after pawn takes pawn now we could
push forward in the center with white
creating a pass pawn
gaining space leaving this night
stranded but um suddenly in this
position
maybe black can take with a knight
suddenly the knight is off
of the edge of the board
utilizing the fact that there's a pin on
this file so pawn takes knight would be
met by rook takes queen don't want to
lose our queen
yeah it's just maybe
a bit of haste from gary i mean it was
the first move that came to my mind as
well
pushing this pawn but now duda he has to
play this i think
it's a bit bit sloppy from gary because
he
well okay i've been a bit critical
because it's not an easy move to see but
he doesn't normally give
chances like that away um he's normally
very good at stopping counter play when
he's commanding a position
yeah so yeah
i mean
let's go back to the players because uh
has duda realized it is he still unhappy
with this position
can we even okay it's not as dark as it
was he's leaning forward
giry in full focus mode meanwhile yeah
that's what you call mood lighting
so whenever his mood improves there's a
little bit of light in the background
yeah actually it has been matching uh
his mood was clearly dark at the
beginning and his opening was terrible
suddenly it's it's okay again maybe a
bit better interesting a little glimmer
of hope yeah maybe we should have that
for all the players in the tour can we
be in
that would charge really fun
and the electric shock machine that you
got uh magnus
when they play a bad move yeah
after this last move by giri i think uh
there would have been a few shocks there
yeah and you can see now the key move
yeah knight takes point on the board
yeah and uh now gary has to
work hard
all over again does it still look better
for a niche or are they back to basics
yeah
i would take white just because white
still has this really nice strong pawn
center but black has solved some issues
black's knight is off the edge of the
board even if it retreats now black's
pawn structure is much improved and also
black has a tube okay he even gives up
material wow wow did not expect that
to be played does this uh
how does this work oh maybe he's going
to grab a pawn on the edge of the board
at the very end wow so first of all we
see a transition where at the very end
white will have two minor pieces a
bishop and a knight for black's rook
traditionally bishop and knight are much
stronger than a rook but black has now
won a second pawn so black has two pawns
on this queen side
past pawns unrivalled that are gonna
march down the board later
suddenly the nature of the position is
completely changed yeah still in white's
favor maybe but he has to be accurate
it's uh yeah maybe i have to show you
guys something i know it's maybe not the
right time now but uh i have to show you
a tweet from shivam yadav
who said what's the worst feeling in the
world just asked just ask duda how he's
feeling right now while his opponent
must be celebrating in ecstasy
and right ta-da
[Laughter]
they promised me it was ready
and it's not but when it's ready when uh
i will uh you can i will show it to you
guys okay it's very very cool we'll
look at that later i'm looking forward
to that yeah interesting duda in a
strange mood today according to his
lights at least it's uh dark it's uh
light
according to his mood and i have to say
the youngsters they're doing good today
sam savion winning game two and jeffrey
chong winning game two they're in their
lead uh they're in the lead in their
matches heading into game threes and
game three has just started between
arjun ergaise and levon aronia if that
is a win for erica easy he will be ready
for the semi-finals we will jump into
that game when this one finishes
the bar
it's definitely liking it for a niche
but you don't 100 agree with the bar
being that optimistic well i do as long
as white is really energetic with his
play um i would completely disagree for
example if the queens come off the board
if white doesn't manage to whip up an
attack against the black king
in this type of situation when you have
the minor pieces
so for example here white bishop and
knight rather than the black brook you
need to go on an attack
you can't just slow the game down trade
off the queens you can't just kind of
meander you can't just uh kind of float
your way through this game you have to
be really accurate really direct that's
why giri i think he's refocusing himself
now he's just kind of finding that
mentality going all out the black king
doesn't have too many defenders around
it and the reason bishop and knight are
better than a rook is simply because
they're two of them
and uh black will only have one defender
a rook if white can use fishman and
knight together to attack a weakness
then uh it should be very strong so what
i would be looking for here for example
from gary uh i mean the first move that
comes to mind would actually be simon's
favorite
definitely about shadow of a doubt yep
pushing this pawn forward [ __ ] it up
yeah got to be done softening up the
king another move if we were to play
with pieces rather than pawns would be
to jump in with the white knight for
example this is actually the weakest
spot in black's camp right now okay he
pushes the pawn but watch out for this
knight jump later looking for weaknesses
and
yeah long term black is doing okay
because black has these two great pawns
but it's about whether black can survive
till the end game to be able to use
these pawns and at least it at least
it's like a free result maybe game now
like previously it looked like white
just couldn't lose in any situation but
now if the queen's come off white can
lose this position uh sometimes you know
blacks might be better right it's
probably better if the queen's
disappeared there is that danger element
now that aneesh has
in the position for dude is this queen's
so far offside it takes at least one
move to get her back to anywhere
kind of decent and also the king on this
diagonal really uncomfortable if you
step in back because of
this kind of battering ram about to
approach
then
what is
geary's idea next that's the big
question
i would be slightly tempted to push his
pawn again
and try to sacrifice something on the
square just to break through towards the
black king but okay we don't find out
the answer to that one if we go back we
see instead duda counter-attack the top
players love to do this
counter-attacking just keeping white
aware that his pieces are loose
okay where to put this rook
as safe as possible i guess yeah yeah
flank up one
are you worried about the back wrangler
yeah this is food
yeah nice and defended i think the king
is pretty safe
it can find a nice shelter on h2 and
doesn't need to worry about any
checkmating ideas that black might have
um whenever you have a bishop on this
square you can nearly never get
checkmated
uh yeah it's rock solid for white okay
well that's what anish likes to hear
being rock solid this is uh game three
they are tied
so um
if anish wins this game it's gonna look
good for him heading into
game four
duda a little bit on tilt is that what
we're seeing from him in this game yeah
it feels like he got a small chance to
get a
semi-decent position and
instead he didn't spend much time on the
clock he completely transformed the
position into one where objectively he
might well be in trouble
so it's yeah it's it's hard to put a
finger on what dude is kind of what's
going through his mind right now
feels like he's just playing moves
without
too much enthusiasm behind them yeah
and on the subject of things going
through
players minds now
we have the tweet ready and it's from
shiva
yadav and he says what's the worst
feeling in the world just ask duda how
he's feeling right now and here it is
i'm sorry i loved it so much i was like
get it on off at night
i could just imagine just seeing that
for
you know
this is probably running through
duda's mind right now you know thinking
oh my goodness me my opponent is like
celebrating when they should not be
happy they should be down in the dumps
it should be me who's on the verge of
perhaps taking it through to the quarter
finals instead he's having to fight the
battle all over again in a worse
position like during a match like this
will you
hate us a strong word will will you kind
of hate your opponent and be angry with
them even if you are maybe friends or in
good terms in between and you know any
other day but on the day with the
matches can you really hate your
opponent
it can happen yeah it can happen in
certain situations it's never temporary
sorry it's never time for it it's never
permanent it's what i wanted to say but
you know you will have that moment also
you know if you see a reaction like
anish did
[Music]
yeah it would just be pure
loathing
and
i'm sorry you just didn't get over that
but
hang on a second i thought that this
move wasn't necessarily possible because
there was going to be a discover check
on the board but uh
well i don't think it works actually
yeah really clever sneaky move there
from duda it looks like this square is a
bit loose uh partly because there's
indirect pressure from this bishop for
example after a queen exchange uh
javanco was mentioning a night jump
jumping out the way with a check hitting
this rook but the problem is after the
night is captured yes white is a piece
up but that's only temporary at the very
end of the variation you have to see
that the white bishop is attacked and
here black is actually up on material
and doing well so yeah unfortunately for
giri there's no direct way after this
queen retreat to punish it um there's no
jumps out the way with the white knight
so instead he drops back his queen he
wants to keep queens on the board as we
mentioned in order to attack the black
king later now this is the threat for
sure the knight jumping out the way for
example if black pushes a pawn that
would be callous because of a knight
check and next move the queen
would be captured
so yeah where to put the queen that is
the question for duda in the current
position
if this is the threat if you offer a
queen trade again and i think that just
gets rejected right
the white rook will block
and no more queen trades
so okay the queen goes back the whole
way your favorite square yeah my
favorite square but maybe not for a
queen no not for the queen bishop bishop
needs to go there maybe the black queen
wants to slide into the corner
[Laughter]
but uh yeah big question is how does
white increase the pressure now yeah
i'll just activate and go for the king i
mean the first thought is to push your
h-pawn but if that doesn't work maybe
you re-root again right um
i mean is there is there anything in the
air here like uh i'd like you know you
always want to calculate capturing that
pawn right i mean uh i i think if bishop
moves you might okay you know nisha has
gotten very safe this also makes a lot
of sense right yeah but now there's no
background checks the white king very
safe but i thought maybe he could move
his light square bishop now to point
against the king because then then that
h pawn moving
at some point would be
if you've got time if you've got time to
build the position up get your pieces to
the most aggressive square as you can
we tried doing that with the queen
but the bishop's not doing much on the
square it's out actually anymore so
and maybe you can start hitting the
queen side as well in some some rare
situations yeah so black started pushing
pawns what else to do for duda these
guys are going to start running yeah and
uh it might be your your maneuver now
simon bishop dropping back another way
to do it maybe
advancing the night yeah it looks like
you might get hit by some pawns you have
to calculate this one really well but
you could try and activate the bishop
this way i wanted to do it
via pushing the g pawn forward
is that any surprise and uh then
returning to the idea of pushing harry
the h pawn up to the fifth row and then
once you've got the opening then
everything can come forward it looks
nice as well yeah yeah
it's got a square for the bishop yeah
yeah many tempting moves should we check
with stockfish just to see how many of
our guesses were correct
i think we suggested three moves there
dropping back the bishop
that is the third best move okay we did
well
um oh we didn't get the other two moves
though so uh the computer thinks that
actually
white should take a time out to stop
black's counter play to maybe target
this weak pawn but that feels like the
wrong side of the board so i'm not sure
how human that is i think giri's already
going to be looking towards the king i
wish we could see where his eyes are
looking on the screen because i have a
definite feeling he's looking on this
side of the board uh but uh the other
move the second top move there by
stopfish that's logical as well using
the white queen going back on this
diagonal to try and target the king
and uh yeah we'll have to see what geary
chooses plenty of choice here
we see three moves in front of us we
also suggested for example dropping the
bishop back pushing this pawn very
logical moving the knight in
also logical
lots of tempting
uh kind of choices here for gary but
that can can be
a double-edged sword especially with
only five minutes on the clock
maybe he has seven or eight moves here
which maintain an advantage but how do
you pick between them
those pawns are moving as well the black
pawns me this is what we're saying when
we mention it's a free result game i
mean those pawns
you know you give black four five tempo
and they become
very scary so
you you need to
you can't just keep moving your king
backwards and forwards okay he's gone
he's gone for the re-router should be
happy simon i'm glad we didn't bet on it
am i happy that anisha's thinking like
me yes i am yeah
it's like bingo isn't it
your numbers have been matched
you're basically the ginger gary
[Laughter]
this is uh game three between these two
they are tied game three has started
between arjunar guys he and them on
aronian if that is a win for
the young indian then he is ready for
the semi-final and the situation is the
same for sam sevillan he is in the lead
and they're now in game three him and
wei if sam savion wins that game he will
be ready for the semi-finals
and the situation is also the same for
jeffree strong the young the other young
american game three will soon start
between himself and richard report he is
in the league jeffrey zhong and with a
win in game three he will be ready for
the semi-final so three of the matches
can actually be decided in game three
but the one we're following in ishgiri
and young christophe do that they will
definitely play four games
and if they still are tied then we will
have tie breaks with blitz and
armageddon but you guys have predicted
that aneesh probably wants to avoid that
he has lost two tie breaks to young
christophe dude on the tour yeah and
this feels like the key game he needs to
use the momentum from that kind of
miracle save that bounce back he had in
the previous
uh in the previous game and yeah if now
he doesn't strike if he doesn't win a
game that he's had an advantage since
move what four or five if he doesn't
strike in this one suddenly momentum's
back on do decide doodle will have white
in the last game and
the uh tie bricks as we mentioned yeah
he's a big big favorite there
so what can i need to do to win this
game the bar is only now saying 0.4
advantage for
an ish well he's got to attack now isn't
he i mean he's got to do something which
he does very well when he does it but it
tends not to do it enough which is just
go all in for the opponent's king i mean
all his pieces are now kind of lined up
against black's king
and i don't see any reason at all why he
shouldn't push the h pawn trying to open
it up more
after black's move i didn't even realize
it's blacksmith of course but like you
know here we go here it comes good stuff
this is going to get very exciting now
definitely and uh take a look at black's
rook it's uh actually moved itself to
the third row but hang on a second i
mean that's there's no defensive purpose
behind that whatsoever does this mean
that uh
anish can just simply
continue with his plan of softening up
the king the black king looks pretty
soft right now i mean the pawns around
it
barely protected black's queen is
protecting a couple of pawns but
even that's not a great piece white's
queen could move out the way white's
knight could start jumping forward a
couple of decent squares tempting
squares is it's actually um dude's idea
to sacrifice his rook for that bishop
wow
maybe because in the current position
for example
if white's knight jumps to the edge of
the board i don't really want to go to
this side to be honest i want to go to
the center but
maybe the black bishop can eliminate
here but uh okay he has done this but if
actually you think maybe at some point
the rook takes bishop will come in
uh into the equation yeah and if white
recaptures then to just say i don't care
i'm a knight down but i'm just going to
push these guys
bank on those two passes on the left
maybe you can push the pawn first is
there actually a fret here yeah in the
current position i mean that's a good
question because if the black pawn
pushes just oh maybe
but maybe you've got knight takes pawn
i don't know
then then you take the bishop
very good and suddenly black gets out
not material down and still with these
pawns be unclear-ish i mean it's it's
like it should be good for white i'm
sure but you could see
you know you could get nervous here and
go wrong with those pawns just maybe
it's easier for black to play that's you
know that that's that's the issue i like
this move just cold-blooded saint gerry
okay it looks like you're threatening
this one but no i will just take back
with the queen
and here your queen drops as well
yeah that's really cold-blooded uh just
utilized the fact that this pin is yeah
and then he has to find a move after
that because black's just gonna keep
pushing those pawns i mean uh yeah i
guess you could move the queen uh but
then you can do ivanka's
plan at least
an extra tempo upright so yeah could
eliminate this you could maybe
i mean it looks so risky but you could
maybe eliminate the white knight
okay the position is on the board and
okay gary goes forward with the white
queen
but now
is there a threat queen takes pawn is
that the threat knight takes pawn maybe
a lot of pressure on this square
knight
do we have the same trick in the air for
example let's say black pushes the pawn
forward again just cold-blooded ignoring
white's threats knight takes pawn is
this just met by rook takes bishop
trying to eliminate this knight next
does white's knight have anywhere good
to jump
not 100 clear maybe the knight just
jumps back but then we have a question
of uh are black's pawn strong enough
maybe white can stop the pawns in this
manner
maybe this is good enough it's getting
really murky isn't it actually i mean
the more i'm looking at the more i'm
thinking
you know
dude has done a great job of creating
counter play yeah at least and at least
this king for now is surviving
all three results again and there it
really is all three results now look at
these squads yeah one slow move from
gary one full step and those pawns will
win the game
really unclear
really really messy uh it's a really
cool matchup anish geary against young
christoph duda top players they have
very different strengths as well it
seems very different strengths
and yeah gary loves to control positions
he loves to use his great strategic
understanding
his great opening preparation duda he's
okay with openings now but he's never
been kind of that's never been his
stronghold uh the openings he's just
once a mess he just wants the initiative
he just wants tricks and yeah talking
about tricks he's doing a great job at
uh establishing them yes and uh i think
that uh anish probably has to take a
time out already if he wants to continue
with his attack
i mean we were talking about dude as
lighting which has now got a little bit
better yeah
very strange also
when anisha's position gets worse his
chair goes down
and he starts getting lower and lower so
he's like nearly under the old areas
he's feeling confident again he's played
a minute okay
so yeah
in with the queen but he suddenly he's
looking at something else he's yeah yeah
what's happening was he checking the
webcam of duda
your valuation bar's gone down so does
gary on the camera it's going the wrong
way isn't he that's the thing as soon as
you you start moving away from the
target zone which is clearly your
opponent's king you know it's
understandable that move get behind the
pawns and try to keep control
but it's just i i really don't know
what's happening anymore in this game
what happens for example if black's rook
just slides across two squares and
attacks the white queen where's the
white queen actually going to hide
hmm
not too many safe squares for her no i
mean the black rook can just continue
attacking the white queen trying to kick
the white queen back out of black's camp
but maybe the position has suddenly
become incredibly wild that that could
be like a logical
result
yeah he's played everything and uh yeah
i think i'll be honest here i might uh
chicken out
and just if i were white and i would
just
move with my queen and keep it on the
seventh and let that rook chase me for
prepared even with the match situation
in mind because a draw here and dude
becomes a huge favor in the remaining
game today and in the tie breaks
and look at this the repetition of moves
is beginning white's queen is hit by a
black rook it moves it gets hit again
yeah that's why i said chicken
and chicken out because you can sort of
come to you can do it zigzag
when you can't keep chasing it i mean i
think you have to play for a win here
really because
it's also hard to change that that you
know you know you're winning you know
you're doing well and suddenly you've
got to take the draw it's gonna be
really depressing playing the next game
but maybe he will go for the draw but
second time we see this position yeah
maybe it's not crazy to do it
okay
he is going for it i mean the thing is
though at the back of your mind you will
be thinking better to draw than to lose
yeah and if you're not quite comfortable
with the position yeah but you can't you
can't play you gotta no you can't play
on i mean
we're like observers we're like not in
the midst of the battles
wise anyone who studied odds anyone
who's been in the heat of tournament
battle in matches you know when your
moment isn't okay there you go good boy
making you guys happy
no draw on this one thank you all right
oh the bar can go away and you'll
probably end up losing but
still still gets a round of applause for
us yes yeah yeah
yeah
the goddess of chess she'll be happy
that he didn't want another draw with
white but he didn't kind of bail out of
a really rich complex position
and now as you mentioned simon the queen
can zigzag back so the white queen can
go back to the a5 square suddenly
keeping an eye on two black pawns and
black's work cannot there we go and
black's rook cannot continue harassing
her
why why is that why is the bar going so
it's still in a niche's
well let's hope
the queen of chess does actually reward
a niche because uh
is that what's the move i don't believe
what the hell what's the best move for
black it's maybe not an obvious one but
it's maybe not too hard to find either
because this pawn is attacked twice by
white's bishop and by white's knight the
best move is simply to move uh to push
it forward
that makes some sense also you clear a
path for the black queen potentially to
check the white king now that white's
queen is so far offside
finds it oh wow
i feel bad now
and if the bishop just retreats what's
the idea that i'm missing maybe there's
a queen check yeah king shuffles i mean
it looks okay to me
it's scary some checkmating ideas
brook's coming in oh dear oh yeah i
missed that one okay but uh yeah he did
stop this from happening i think the
moral of the story here guys is that
never put your queen on a5 duda
the reason he didn't win the previous
game he put his queen on this exact
square and then his king was attacked on
this exact square uh so isn't the moral
of story just take a draw whenever you
can
just take the
grab the drawer you know take the drawer
always no you can go you can go for the
win it just has to be
a bit measured um
yeah now it's all gone wrong it's all
gone completely wrong
it doesn't he doesn't deserve to lose
him he doesn't
absolutely i mean the gods have not been
kind well he's got to keep the queens on
we've said if the queen's come off it i
totally agree it's gone wrong because
those pawns the player for white is one
of your bishops is hanging as well the
dark squared bishop for white is
attacked so if you save your queen you
have to give up your dark square bishop
well let's say you move the queen two
squares fours because i i just think the
ending's going to be very easy for black
so i i have to have to gamble here the
black king is is still very weak so
let's let's try queen up two squares
maybe yeah the only square at least to
try that trade the queens and you just
lose yeah yeah two black pawns are too
strong you've got no choice there
okay look how dude suddenly his camera
is all bright again he's loving life
yeah it really is
all right well you are suggesting for
anish now with two minutes left on the
clock to move his queen
two squares up yes attack the rook it's
got to try right yeah i mean the rook is
defended that's the problem so you will
just drop your bishop the whole idea
would be to swing white's queen across
on the seventh rank maybe give a check
i'm not sure what next that is the issue
for gary
and giri hates sacrificing unless he
sees there's something specific
he's going for it he has to do it
processive elimination yeah i mean i
taking the bishop looks very risky
though doesn't it i mean it does i mean
you've got at least a draw bishop check
no you haven't because the king goes in
the corner right i see yeah there's but
there's a few moves right i mean i
personally would take the bishop
well okay black's only
winning move but the only move to
get an advantage is to drop the black
queen back two squares
that's not obvious oh oh
dropping the black queen back actually
taking the white bishop which we were
assuming is the key move that as simon
mentioned leads to a draw 0.0 we don't
see why it's a draw it's still very
complicated but it could go either way
dropping the black queen back two
squares mirroring the white queen
trying to force a queen trade
that is the key
again the key is you want to force the
white queen to the a5 square that seems
to be the kind of cursed square in this
match
and uh only once the white queen gets
off the seventh rank then you take its
bishop
wow oh he's found it
well brilliant
is incredible
i mean the last game i i mean uh anish
turned it totally around from a
completely lost position this game is
it's going the other way uh dude has
turned it around are we gonna see him
in a bit of ecstasy as well maybe um i
mean
he's he's he's played brilliantly to
defend this but i do actually well i
mean i felt for duder in the last game
but i'm really feeling for a niche you
shouldn't be punished for trying to win
a game of chess really you know it's
just not fair
so but the goddess of chess may be still
bitter about that first game of the day
when anish took a draw with white oh
that's why that's why yeah yeah
that's it he took the draw in the first
game
there is some justice
but uh look at this black has two
squares two good squares to go to one
was a bad square but he did find the
best square um the safest for the black
king
incredible i mean it's
there's actually a way to win a piece
right now for white but black's pawns
would just win the game so in the
current position white can actually be
flashy i think and give up the white
queen you can even take on this square
with a check
you give up your queen for a rook but
then you jump in with a knight fork it
looks like you're winning
the black king moves takes a bishop
because at the end you save your own
bishop and you win the black queen in
the process you emerge with an extra
knight but we've been talking about
these black pawns and
i think one of them is going to win the
game you just push forward simply and
the white knight tries to ride back to
the rescue the other black pawn steps
forward and
these are going to cost white at least a
piece maybe even more they're just too
strong
so it's almost similar to a previous
game we saw with every guy see an
ironian it's just a pawn race and
queen side pawns when they've got
nothing stopping them when your
opponent's pieces are distracted they
can be such a good trump card and okay
the white queen is back on that cursed
square uh on a5 if we go back to the
current position and
the question is do you take this bishop
do you get brave can't you trap the
queen
now oh with the rook yeah maybe i mean
unless there's some
where are you going you've got night no
night check just knight checks just
drops the bishop
wow is this just simple now for yeah
let's go back to the players it looks
like simon's found the winning move
uh i don't see a reply
i mean
i don't see it
the queen is trapped
so you're right simon yeah it's weird
because you're looking if you can get
the bishop to d6 if you can get the
knight in a good check then
but i i can't see
anything that's quite good enough here
do you think gary spotted it suddenly
yeah looking he's barely breathing yeah
yeah well i i think that's also not
their only way to win i i i was also
looking at uh threatening checkmate
just to set the
heart rate fluttering but i love your
move simon that is just put it in the
bank
victory assured seriously guys there's
something about the white queen on the
a5 square today that's just what got
wrong in the last game every time he's
put it on that square this this what
second third time he's done it this game
is it's gone bad computers hated it and
now
queen trap dude defines it white's queen
is
doomed no safe squares dude has played
so well in this game from from the
horrible position to he's done
everything right he's complicated it
he's mixed up and it's not even really
that clear where a niche went wrong yeah
actually i mean we we were well i was
kind of playing most of anish's move
anyway so it's like i'm not even sure
what he did wrong actually which is even
though he's probably winning you know
plan of maybe using the white queen and
going off to the side of the board was
maybe wrong yeah sure he could have
still gone for a draw after that but
yeah
take the draw always take the draw it
doesn't matter if you're if you're
completely winning just take the draw
and be safe
solid solid is the way to go hindsight
that's uh definitely worth a wisdom for
giri but
okay he's got less than 10 seconds he
needs to find a move there's just no way
to keep your queen on the board
nothing two seconds okay he gives a
desperate night check but after the
black king takes the white light squared
bishop last game over gary is about to
resign what a change in emotions from
the last the last game i mean
painful to see and look at the light now
dude the light comes on he is like he's
like the enlightened one
bang yeah hallelujah
that is uh the sound inside young
christophe duda's head right now he wins
game three to take the lead in the
quarterfinal match against anish geary
and look at a niche heartbreak shaking
his head